okay
are you guys
all right I want to thank everybody for
uh for covering the story today I want
to thank Ambassador Haley for coming to
the Border seeing it firsthand uh once
you see it you can't unsee it and that
was uh that was clear today I grew up
partly in Camp Wood a small little town
Temple Hills in Edwards County and I
remember we had a small little ranch you
could blindfold me and I knew every inch
of that place and I feel as if I know
every inch of the district that I
represent and sadly our district is
turned upside down we started the uh the
morning in Hondo Texas and the reason
why we went to Hondo is because what's
happening in Hondo is happening all
across Highway 90 whether it's kanipa
whether it's the Hennis whether it's
humality whether it's Eagle Pass and
there's a train that comes from Mexico
through San Antonio that often carries
illegal immigrants and Elite immigrants
on that train they jump off they die
sometimes they get maimed so we started
the day in Hondo and in Hondo there was
a saying the town has a saying don't
this is God's country don't drive
through there like hell and I'll tell
you in Texas 23 not only are we the
epicenter of this border crisis it feels
as if it is hell for us and I think we
got to see some of that today after
Hondo we went to uh Del Rio
we went to Delroy and went to the San
Antonio shoes Factory
the reason why I went to this I want to
highlight while the security on the
border takes a lot of attention and a
lot of what is happening there is so
much more to border communities than
just what we see on TV and uh at this
facility here you have a an American
American-owned American-made company
that is fighting for manufacturing that
is making shoes and what's so special
about it is you have many of them in the
manufacturing that are helping out over
500 employees are women and they're
Hispanic and it's a beautiful seed of
things a beautiful thing to see they get
up every day and they go to work they
live their lives they make it a better
life for themselves and their family
that is the American dream that is
happening right there every day in Del
Rio then we went to a ranch the whaleys
and we met with uh with County Judge we
met with Sheriff we met with ranchers
and we got to see firsthand the hell
that they're dealing with the the
trafficking that is happening every
single day the fences that are being cut
uh just the the violation the sheer
violation of their properties and what
what this serves me the most is it's
gotten so bad along order
but now it feels normal there's nothing
normal about this crisis there's so much
pain and anguish that is happening in
this crisis we also met with the
tambundas that that bundas are a family
that just a couple weeks ago
lost their mother she lost her mother
and she lost her seven-year-old daughter
imagine that you're in Ozona Texas small
little town in West Texas your mother
takes your daughter to go to a play date
with her cousins
and on the way home a Smuggler
going 100 miles an hour crashes into
your family and destroys your family
this is in Ozona Texas a hundred and
twenty miles from the Rio Grande
but guess what it says if they're right
on the Rio Grande
doesn't matter if you're in Hondo if
you're in a Zona you're an Eagle pass
everybody's lives are turned upside down
and we visited the last stop we visited
was here in Eagle Pass where we saw
another Rancher and the community just
turned upside down the traffic said it's
happening I know uh Ambassador Haley I
really appreciate
the energy and the effort Eagle Pass is
not an easy place to get to uh our our
most famous resident bill malusion for
Fox News he knows that firsthand and
here you are and uh and I'm grateful for
that I know you have a plan you have you
have a lot of ideas for secure in the
Border I agree with their ideas I agree
with their plan I would add three other
things before I turn it to the
Ambassador one it's time to take the
gloves off it's time to get to the root
of this border crisis and it's time to
label cartels as terrorist organizations
I'm committed to that two we have to end
Catch and Release well those are words
how do you end Catch and Release to me
as an appropriate I'm blessed to sit on
the Appropriations Committee in the
house
you end Catch and Release by defunding
vhs's catch and release program it's
that simple and the last thing I would
say is fentanyl is killing our kids
Smugglers are killing our kids it's time
to throw the book at them it's time to
hold these these these uh Smugglers and
folks responsible for preventing all
deaths accountable and it's not possible
legislation I'm grateful to have the
Ambassador Haley here you know the Eagle
Pass and uh with that I'd love to turn
it over
thank you first of all I want to thank
Tony Gonzalez and you know you should
just know that he is the Border King I
mean because he's got 800 miles of
divorce so there is no one that can ever
say that they understand the Border more
than Tony Gonzalez and the if he is not
in every single immigration conversation
in Congress something is wrong you know
you look at what we saw today and the
first thing I'll tell you is we are a
country of rocks the second we stop
being a country of law is we give up
everything this country was founded on
what I saw today was that their
elections
a president has one job one job and
that's to keep Americans safe there is
nothing that is keeping Americans safe
like what we saw today there is first of
all no border there are pieces of a
border but there's really no borders
secondly they don't see border patrol or
any National Guard unless Tony shows up
the people the ranchers said that but
all of a sudden when they show up
Suddenly they're votes on the river
otherwise you're not seeing them they
show up when they know you guys are
watching but what we did was we talked
to the Ranchers
and if you talk to the ranchers this is
their private property they invested us
and what we saw
the amount of clothes and trash and
paraphernalia and stuff that's left on
their property that they have to pay to
clean it
that they go and you see clothes along
what is a makeshift fence
and they actually find bodies on the
other side alive or not
kind of America is this
so you look at what Joe Biden is allowed
to have happen he thinks if he doesn't
talk about the Border crisis it doesn't
exist he thinks if he tells my orcas not
to call it a crisis it won't happen this
is a crisis and it's not just a crisis
for the people of Texas this is a crisis
for every American family because when
you look guess what happens when they
leave Del Rio in Eagle Pass they're not
staying here they're coming to your
state they're going into your school
they're going into your hospitals your
law enforcement officers are suddenly
having to deal with them they are now
taking up your taxpayer dollars when
someone comes here through legal
immigration they have to be sponsored
guess who all these illegal immigrants
are sponsored by the taxpayers of
America you are paying for them because
all of a sudden they are going into our
community and billions of dollars have
gone to funds illegal evidence so what
do we do about it the way we fix it is
we go back to what I did in South
Carolina you do a mandatory e-verify
program which makes sure that you hire
no illegal no business can hire any
illegal immigrants the second thing is
you make sure that we don't we fire the
87 000 IRS agents and hire at least 25
000 border patrol and Ice agents so that
we can go and give these other border
patrol agents the help they need I
talked to border patrol today do you
know what they said their job is
babysitting babysitting that's all
they're doing they said if they were
just allowed to do their job that things
could get better
stop the taxpayer handouts for these
illegal immigrants make sure that we're
defunding Sanctuary cities there are
Sanctuary cities all around here why is
that allowed to happen we should not
give one penny to a sanctuary too
because what they're doing is they're
giving Safe Haven to these illegal
immigrants that are coming over we need
to make sure we go back to romaina
Mexico because that has stopped and we
need to make sure that we keep title 42
the concern the ranchers had is what
happens in May when title 42 goes away
you think we've got hundreds coming
across now you're going to have
thousands coming across and who's
talking about it no one and then the one
thing that could make the biggest
difference
stop Catch and Release and go to catch
and Deport when you start deporting
these illegal immigrants they will stop
coming right now on social media they're
telling their other cartels where to
bring people through what passages to
take how to get there what to say when
they get there
where are we doing this
stop the insanity because we're doing
this to ourselves and what I will say
is this is not a Republican or Democrat
issue this is a national security issue
we know that Iranians are saying right
now the easiest way to come into America
through the southern borders are we
waiting for a 9 11 moment what is it
that we're waiting on so what I'll say
is first of all Biden needs to open his
mouth and say this is a crisis he needs
to let his cabinet agencies say that
this is a crisis and they need to start
dealing with it and Congress needs to
get in a room and fix it the days of
them getting on TV and talking about it
and not seeing what Tony sees every day
and hearing from the families every day
it's irresponsible and they need to
start getting there and doing something
about it let me tell you what's going to
happen
right now you've got illegal immigrants
coming across they are your new section
of homes
because there is no one there to take
care of it so look on a corner street
near you look for a tent city somewhere
near you because when they come over
there is no one that is going to take
care of them so we have got to start
taking care of the American people I
will tell you when I run for president
this will be one of our top priorities
is to make sure we acknowledge the
crisis that it is and I'll tell you when
you look at these families the number
one thing they said is
people need to not expect us to just
live with this and I'll tell you live
one day on one of those ranches and see
what they see and carry a gun like they
have to and worry about whether their
kids are safe and worry about whether
their home is going to be broken into if
you would live like that then leave it
like this if you would not live like
that don't make these families live
like that so my big
question is when is Biden coming to the
Border we've given up on comma when is
Biden coming to the Border secondly
when's Congress going to do something
Republicans and Democrats need to get in
a room and get it done they owe it to
the American people it's time that we
see that happen thank you we'll open it
up for any questions
sauce so I was speaking with many
ranchers here in Maverick County were
telling me how they were seeing a lot of
these godaways that were trespassing and
many times aren't into their properties
and they were telling me on file that
the City attorney was actually telling
them that they're not allowed to
apprehend these people and we're
actually looking to prosecute one of
these ranchers uh is there anything in
Congress that's being done to make sure
that these City attorneys can uh not
tell people that they can't defend their
own property
which are seeing is lawlessness
happening along the border and honestly
it starts and it ends with the federal
government it starts and it ends with
President Biden President Biden is
failing America and he is shackling
border patrol it's border Patrol's job
border patrol agent's job in order to
apprehend people that are that come into
our country illegally but because
they're vacant because they're doing
other things all of a sudden everyone
else is trying to build that Gap whether
it's sheriffs whether it's DPS whether
it's local PD or ranchers themselves and
it's completely unfair to absolutely
everyone so what needs to happen is
pretty simple the federal government Joe
Biden needs to do his damn job it is
that simple we need to enforce the laws
that are already in the books and as
Ambassador Haley mentioned if you do not
qualify for Asylum which is about 88 of
votes instead of getting flown to New
York or L.A or anywhere else you get
flown back to your country of origin
this program already exists repatriation
flights all Biden had Biden doesn't need
anything other than just to turn that on
I don't want to add anything no I mean
you know the one thing when I ask the
sheriff when did the switch go on when
did you start to see a problem they said
when they started doing Catch and
Release when they stopped remain in
Mexico and they're worried about title
42. this is not rocket science this is
about the fact just to ensure what we
know works this isn't about which
president did it first it's not about
which party is the war against it it's
not what's the right thing to do right
we absolutely absolutely should make
them as terrorist organization I mean if
you look at the fact we had
enough fentanyl across the border last
year that we've killed every single
American fentanyl is now the number one
cause of death for people ages 18 to 49.
000 people died in 2021 alone one second
and the car tells if they're not
trafficking dogs are trafficking people
either way what they're doing is
terrorist activity and we need to deal
with that and we've got the intelligence
to do it we've got the Special
Operations members to do it we just need
to get it done but is there a
consideration
yourself
so they might
kind of counter each other a little okay
we don't want card sales coming into
America what good is that our job is to
protect America first right and so we
don't want cartels coming across this
country we don't want children traffic
and we don't want drugs coming over the
first thing is we need to go to China
and tell them to stop sending the
fentanyl they know exactly what they're
doing the second thing is you've got to
deal with the cartels and stop them
where they're planted they're planted in
Mexico and let's do that and trust me
when illegals realize they're going to
have to remain in Mexico they won't come
because they don't want to sit next door
it sends a message to them it's best to
process where they're at to make the
track when they know they're not going
to make it
I just want to add I just want to add
briefly about a year ago there were
these five little girls who were
abandoned in a field in Camaro and and
there's some people that look at those
girls and they think they're the problem
those those girls were basically
exploited I look at I don't see those
little baby girls as a problem I see the
cartels that dump them there as the
problem this this morning if you were
with uh Sheriff Brown in Medina County I
asked them hey do you think we should
label cartels as terrorist organizations
absolutely because that's what they are
we asked a Rancher here in Del Rio if we
should label cartels and terrorist
organization he said absolutely because
that's what they are I asked uh two
border patrol sector Chiefs under oath
in a hearing if we should label cartels
as tourist organizations these are
border patrol experts I've been doing it
for 30 years they said absolutely a
Sheriff from from Arizona we should
absolutely label cartels as terrorist
organizations I think we need to figure
out how legally to maneuver that so that
way we don't create an asylum area that
kind of welcomes people over but they're
terrorists the cartels are terrorizing
America and guess what they're working
with China I mean no one's talking about
the fentanyl but guess where the
fentanyl is coming from it starts in
China and then it comes to the cartels
and then it kills Americans if you
actually if you listen to law
enforcement or border patrol if we just
listen to them they know exactly how to
fix the problem is no one in DC is
listening to them and that's what we
need to do
house before
I think first of all is all the things
that I just laid out for the legal
immigration plan you do that but when it
comes to actual immigration laws itself
instead of doing quotas every year on
how many we're going to let through you
partner with your businesses and see
what they need and when you do that all
that all South Carolina we've got
farmers and we've got a tourist tourist
industry that's always looking for work
when you start to listen to your
businesses and do what they need all of
a sudden the economy goes up people are
put
to everything gets better and I think
you know people do the illegal
immigration plan that you put in place
and then you add immigration reform on
top of that and you make it a priority
and call it the crisis that it is that's
why
yeah
centered yourself when you answer the
questions okay thanks
yeah we have one here so Joy Addison Fox
News I have a two-part question so the
first one is about asylums Asylum
Seekers there's been some confusion on
where people can seek Asylum if they can
legally seek Asylum between border
checkpoints
um do you plan to have some
clarification on that I guess going
forward and then the second part is with
DPS and border patrol agents saying that
they're overwhelmed National Guard has
come in to help but will there be a
point where even I guess National Guard
doesn't have the resources to bring in
how we've been fixed just them being
overwhelmed with the issue
the problem is a majority of the people
claiming Asylum are not actually
eligible to to get Asylum a lot of them
have just been told what to say and
we've heard that today from one of the
chairs is they basically in real time
change what they say so that they sit
within the Asylum walls so we have to
first make sure that we're processing it
properly and we're betting it properly
right now that betting is not happening
the second thing is you know everybody
wants to know how many border patrol how
many ice ages how many National Guard
you wouldn't be near the number if we
just enforce the laws you wouldn't need
near the number if you put remain in
Mexico if you still
that's the key is first do those things
that you know will stop the flow then go
and add to the the Border agents but let
them do their job right now my husband
he's in the military he's got military
members who stood on that order before
with a clicker all they do is click on
how many people go through they're not
allowed to capture them they're not
allowed to do anything to them let's let
border patrol do their job let the
National Guard what are they doing
they're standing there because no one
will actually let them do something so
first let's give them the powers to do
what they need to do and then let's look
at the numbers
I think right now we've got to do
something right I mean it it in May if
this is all ended you're gonna have
thousands come across to me I see
National Security threats coming across
that's you know that's our job is to not
allow any sort of threats impact America
when that's happening it's you know
Biden if Biden won't do anything then
our job is to keep title 42 in place if
Biden would actually enforce the laws we
wouldn't have to be doing anything like
that but we don't have a president
that's important
hi um can you talk a little bit about
your immigration reform plans I know
there are people who are waiting for
years and years decades to come you know
through the legal process how would you
address that the people who've been
waiting for such a long time and it's an
important Point she was talking about
the the immigration plans we had in
place first of all you have people who
put in the time put in the money do it
the right way and it takes them eight in
10 and 12 years to get processed why is
it that they we're hurting those that
are doing the right thing and we're
allowing people to come across just in
24 hours and go wherever they want
that's all the more reason why we have
to secure the border and follow the
rules but with regular immigration we've
got take all the bureaucracy down our
number one goal should be who do we
bring into this country that makes our
country better you do it on Merit you do
who our businesses need you do what
talent we need and you focus on that the
second thing you do is you focus on what
our businesses need when you look at
what our businesses need and you match
it up with the talent then you're all of
a sudden making America stronger you're
making it economically stronger and
you're making the episodes so that's the
and then you just take down the wait
time we don't have enough processes and
you've got too many people sitting on
paper and not doing their job to be
honest we need to go in there and just
break it
clean it up and then start back over
that's the only way to get that
integration process done
yet I know you said that you've given up
on my size
but would you say that what are you
talking about
overall or who do you think
these questions
we have one President we have one
president and his job is to keep
Americans safe and all we know is that
he's refusing to look at the border
situation because he hopes it goes away
so now he's got my orchest who's been
given the trouble of dealing with this
and he's refused to cause it a crisis so
how do the American people have any
confidence in a president who refused to
see a border problem and a secretary who
refuses to see it as a crisis it shows
that you've got an Administration that's
in it and not responsible and putting
American people at risk and I would ask
the Democrats is this who you're going
to put back up for president next year
because you're basically telling America
make sure you live with this illegal
immigration problem because this
president's not doing anything to change
it and the Democratic party is going to
go right alongside him
elected president you always when you
were the person at the top everything
falls under your job is to make sure you
fix every problem every crisis and if
your secretary can't do it you replace
your secretary and you get one that can
the buck stops advice and that's been
shown not to me
all right guys thank you so much
appreciate your time